I've got an interesting relationship
with with the concept of risk I
personally believe that you you know
you're really not going to innovate that
much if you don't take risk experimental
electric 89 Trail Yankees departing fre3
for left
traffic I'm not a dared you know I'm not
a um I'm not a big risk taker I would
never Skydive or bungee jump or anything
like that but there are those times when
I strap into the airplane and it's like
I have to acknowledge the fact that I
can be killed doing this I got a problem
I've lost uh lost
power one day when I was 36 I walked
away from my desk job and set off on the
journey to become a motorcycle
racer
I started as an amateur and I did it on
the weekends and I got hooked I got into
professional ranks in in just two years
um and then I broke my
pelvis it it made me sit back at a desk
again um and so I was very restless and
I decided to get a couple guys from
Boeing and come up with an electric
motorcycle none of us had ever designed
an electric vehicle we all just came
into a little a storage unit that we
rented and built the thing from the
ground up and you know it ended up
becoming the world's fastest electric
motorcycle all my life I've been really
excited about gas engines but when I got
introduced to electric motors I was
converted overnight the electric motors
is better in almost every
respect the problem with electric
vehicles as people know is is not the
motor it's the batteries and so as
batteries get better we're going to see
more and more shifting to electric
vehicles so we're sitting on this
electric motorcycle that set all these
records and it made us Wonder well if we
got away with that what else can we do
and we decided to build this electric
airplane airplanes now are loud and
dirty and they burn a lot of gas so we
thought if we want to make it an impact
this is the perfect application for our
technology
the first flight of this airplane um I
was very
apprehensive I went down the runway
really having no idea whether the
airplane was going to fly or
not and it flew next day I decided to
fly it again and see how fast it would
go so the French had the speed record at
about 175 mph and we thought we can we
can probably beat that with what we've
got okay see you guys later I basically
floored it level flight 202
milph and so we're celebrating you know
on the radio yay we did it 202 mph and
then pow there's this
pop and the cabin starts filling up with
like a gas you know 89 I think I might
have damed some batter no power at all
and I had to Glide this airplane and try
to make it back to the
runway
at the last minute I thought I'm going
to skip Off The Runway and crash into
the
desert my main Wheels touched and then I
just stalled out the front wing and got
it on the ground it was the most
outrageous thing that I've ever pulled
off in my life wo holy
crap we demonstrated that this electric
airplane can actually beat gasoline
airplanes in speed and climb but it
won't fly very long so it only fly about
an hour and 20 minutes and so to address
that we're building another electric
airplane and trying to fly it across the
Atlantic using a series of battery
powered drones to recharge me as I go it
takes five drones for me to get from New
York to Paris and they're coming from
different places meeting me and keeping
me flying as I go across if we pull this
off electric airplanes could be
available for everybody I get it wrong
they're fishing me out of the Atlantic
it's it's wholly impractical it's it's
super dangerous and uh I want to do
it I'm at a juncture now where I've done
this crazy R&D we've build up a huge
patent portfolio how do we commercialize
it how do we make it reliable and safe
and and take an electric airplane to
where Elon Musk has taken an electric
car we're building something for the US
Navy um we've got an R&D contract with
them and I'm working on a venture that
we will fund with venture capital a
drone delivery service if you have a
dream and you're doing something that
you don't want to be doing you know life
is passing you by a small person and a
group of ragtag volunteers can can do
pretty cool
stuff